in the beginning social gaming company
was started by a Harvard MBA Mark Pincus
already the veteran of the handful of
Silicon Valley startups named for his
Bulldog it became Zynga and had the good
fortune to tie itself to a young
Facebook launching Texas Hold'em poker
on Facebook in 2007 mega hits followed
Mafia Wars in 2008 farmville in 2009 and
quickly
Zynga became the number one app maker on
the social network venture investors
swarm to the startup Reid Hoffman
Peter Thiel Yuri Milner Union Square
Ventures kleiner perkins even Google by
the end of 2009 the company had 207
million monthly active users 28% of them
on the site every single day but some
problems started to emerge for example
only two and a half percent of the users
actually paid Zinka anything and there's
an IPO loomed the accounting it singer
got interesting Zynga made a bunch of
legal accounting changes effectively
taking revenues from the future pulling
them forward without these changes
Zynga would have lost money every single
quarter but with the changes profits
appeared and so did an IPO at a seven
billion dollar valuation a few months
later with a valuation of ten billion
dollars the company added a secondary
offering CEO Pincus sold two hundred
million dollars worth of shares but the
stock began falling and in late 2012
sales began falling never to recover
layoffs began in size 2846 employees
felt a fewer than 2000 employees kleiner
perkins took another seat on the board
and Pincus was out as CEO bumped up the
chairman he was replaced by the
Electronic Arts an Xbox executive Don
matric in July 2013 they forgot a 1
million dollar salary a five million
dollar signing bonus and over 10 million
restricted stock units in Zynga the
company cut games as tens of millions of
users fled the platform down to 123
million by the
2013 so at the end of the year of matrix
tenure the same problems exist can they
draw in more users can they launch
another hit game and can the company
prove that it can launch games with the
same skill which it launched a stock